Yank speaks is sponsored by express VPN protect your online privacy
today@expressvpn.com slash yang.
When we were looking to give a million bucks away to the folks in the Bronx,
like I was like, we have to make it. So every dime goes to a human,
like I do not want to be like, again, not mad at nonprofits, like run one,
but we got to like find a thousand people and give them a thousand bucks. Um,
and we did it. I was very, very proud of that. We need more like that,
where we just got to get money into people's hands. And remember the Congress,
this is the only silver lining can we're in a deep dark hole.
It's a terrible catastrophic time,
but there's a huge appetite to do something differently. Again,
74% of Americans want cash relief.
Like we're going to get president Biden and then we're going to need a new,
new deal.
And it's going to be hopefully a chance to write some of the wrongs that have
been weighing our country down for generations.
Welcome back to yang speaks this week.
I sit down with Karen Hunter whose radio show I visited when I was running for
president. Really enjoyed this conversation. Hope you do too.
We got Andrew Yang about to come in to talk with us.
Maybe he'll be mayor of New York one day. I don't know,
but he's here today to talk about basic income and a host of other things that
he's working on. Let me welcome back to the show, our pal,
Mr. Andrew Yang. Uh.
Hello, Karen. Thank you for having me. Uh,
it's great to be here again. I feel like I'm coming home.
Hey, you know what? Um,
that just gave me chills and made me feel really good inside.
Thank you for that. You are home. So you are, um,
I've had your ma you you've been on my mind, uh, since well,
since the last time you were on, but the,
the 11 mayors throughout the country who signed this letter about basic income,
and then we're seeing another stimulus possibly come down the pike.
And I was like,
if they had just done the basic income thing that Andrew Yang was running on,
maybe this wouldn't be such a horrific time to, to be here in this country.
You're a hundred percent right, Karen,
where unfortunately now we're in like this pandemic fueled a recession that
could become a depression and we need to get money into people's hands.
So I've been doing my best to both make that case to members of Congress.
There's an emergency cash relief bill that literally 74% of Americans
support does getting money into our hands. Uh, can you think of something else,
74% of Americans support at this point? Like what do you,
what do you have to do to try and get that higher?
A majority of Republicans and Democrats.
So let's talk some sense into our legislators and get economic
relief into our hands.
I wish it didn't have to be like in this tragic and devastating a time,
but it's overdue.
Well, Jack Dorsey, the CEO of Twitter just announced that he's, uh,
donating $3 million to those mayors. Uh,
I think the mayor California Stockton has been doing it
successfully. So he was one of the, the leading ones, chocolate Lumumba,
Keisha Lance bottoms is a bunch of mayors all over there.
Veronica, you know, a bunch of people. Um,
I was on a panel with mayor Tubbs of Stockton, uh, last year.
And he said something to me. I probably, probably not supposed to share,
but I'll share it because you know, whatever we're here. Um, but he said to me,
after the panel, he said like, Andrew, you can say.
I could never get away with saying, okay. And,
and what he meant by that was that like, I was just up there being like, look,
we have to value people, intrinsically have to get,
give everyone a basic income and the rest of it. And last year he was like,
if a young black mayor were to say that, like people would be like,
what the heck are you talking about? He's like, but now it's not just him.
It's Keisha Lance bottoms. It's Ross, Baraka and new work.
It's mayors around the country.
And they're going to be many more because if you're a mayor and you see what's
happening in your community, you're going to say like, wait a minute.
Like we need to do things differently.
So, so tell me what the disconnect is. And I've watched it around welfare.
I've watched it.
There's like this notion in this country that if we give somebody something that
somehow it takes something away from me. And so it is a weird thing,
but I literally watched the government print money,
trillions of dollars and give it to people and no one had a problem with it.
And I'm like, Oh, so we could just print money and just give it to people.
We could have been doing it the whole time. Karen,
I asked the brutal truth and Martin Luther King saw this in the sixties.
He was like, we should have a basic income today.
And he was killed while he was making that case.
And somehow we've been brainwashed into this nonsense myth that like, Oh,
we don't have enough to go around. It's been nonsense for a long time.
And this pandemic has demonstrated to all of us when push came to shove,
like you just said,
did we just print $4 trillion for wall street when they needed a bailout? Yes.
Did we just print $4 trillion for big companies?
And to some extent ourselves, like during this pandemic, yes, we can do it.
We just need enough members of Congress to get on board with the fact that they
work for us. They don't work for Amazon.
They don't work for the giant companies that have been laughing their way,
all the way to the bank for the last number of years and decades.
When, when you were talking about universal, basic income is, you know,
during the election cycle, et cetera. Um,
I was always wondering like,
were there other places that actually made it work?
And you've given a couple of examples,
like even I saw recently that you had tweeted about South Africa
is on it. It's on its way to,
to creating a floor for universal income. Right?
Talk about where the rest of the world he is on days.
Because I think it's such a foreign concept to so many, uh,
so many Americans that they think it's not possible. Right.
But there are precedents for this,
like literally in places throughout the world.
Yeah.
South Africa just announced that they're going to make it happen for everyone.
Uh, India is actually implementing a version of it, uh,
to tens hundreds of millions of people, Canada.
They did it like a full on UBI trial and an entire town for years.
And in that town, you saw better health, mental health, more people,
starting businesses, more people going back to school. It was beautiful.
And when they found that data, they were like, this is,
this is exactly what we should have been doing this entire time. Like,
the data is like Indiana Jones, you know,
like rate as the lost Ark where like the data was like,
it's a freaking warehouse or filing cabinet where people were
trying to keep it from public eye. But then when they found it, they were like,
Oh my gosh. Like, so they're like you said,
there are examples of this happening around the world.
And the most compelling example,
I think tens of millions of Americans just experiences.
Like everyone got 1200 bucks and everyone liked it, loved it.
Like it didn't make anyone, all of a sudden being like, Oh,
like work is for like losers or something.
It shut down because you gave its citizens their money back, right?
Like government didn't stop because we gave citizens some of their money back.
Right? Yeah. And it helped the economy greatly. It,
it like reduce the poverty rate,
but it also went back right into local businesses to groceries, to fuel,
to rent. Uh,
and we are the citizens and the re the stakeholders of the richest society in
the history of the world, like $22 trillion pre crisis,
we can a hundred percent afford this. Dr. King knew it in the sixties.
He was like, we can afford this. Now he was right.
Then it's even more true today than it was. Then.
It's just so baffling that there's so much resistance.
And it's always around this notion of laziness,
this myth of laziness that will somehow, you know,
lull people into not getting up and pulling herself themselves up by their
bootstraps.
When you go online, they're watching who's. They unfortunately,
a lot of people and you know, here on yang speaks,
we're big fans of our data being ours and of data rights and have data privacy.
We started the data dividend project to fight for your data rights.
But in the meantime,
what can you do so that when you go online internet service providers,
aren't keeping track of that data and then selling it. So what you do about it,
incognito mode, unfortunately, doesn't work quite as well as you hope it would.
So what you can do is what a lot of companies do for their employees.
You can use a virtual private network.
Now the one that we recommend your yang speaks is express VPN.
It's an app that reroutes your internet connection through their secure servers.
So your ISP can't see the sites you visit.
It keeps all your information secure by encrypting a hundred percent of your
data with the most powerful encryption available. You click one button,
you forget about it.
You don't even realize you have it on it's like all of your devices are just
getting piped through this fancy, fun,
new network that you can call your own protect your online activity today with
the VPN rated, number one by CNN and wired visit my exclusive link express
vpn.com/yang.
And you can get an extra three months free on one-year package. That's E X,
P R E S S vpn.com/yang express,
vpn.com/yang. To learn more, keep your data safe and secure.
We're talking with two Andrews, Andrew McCaskill, of course, Andrew Yang.
You also are out talking about police reform and cash
relief. Talk a little bit about what, what it is. You're proposing Andrew Yang.
On the police reform style side of things.
I looked at the data because I'm a data guy, Karen,
and the data is shocking where you're seeing cities around the
country pound over a billion dollars a year in civil suits for police misconduct
and brutality, uh,
and the legal standard to successfully Sue a police officer is very high.
So if you were seeing successful suits at over a billion dollars a year,
you know that the magnitude of the problem is multiple billions of dollars.
And this is literally bankrupting,
some towns where some cop does something reprehensible,
and then the entire police department gets. And now at this point,
you have to look at it and say,
this is a rampant problem in is like many of the problems we're talking about
has been in place for years.
And when I talked to a black lives matter activist about this,
he actually hit the nail on the head. He said, look,
local DA's cannot control cops in their area,
because if you're the da in that area,
you literally rely upon law enforcement every day,
just to do your job and make cases.
And then for you to turn around and being like, Hey, bad cops,
like we're going to bust you all.
But like the local da is like Kamala Harris case at the same thing,
she was like, you know, you can't expect the locals to do this.
So what I proposed, uh,
was that you need a federal department of justice commission that ideally be
named after George Floyd, that all their mission was,
was to investigate issues around police misconduct. And if you're a local da,
you would celebrate because finally it would be something off your plate.
And you know that there are issues, you know, there are bad cops in your area,
but you can't do much about it. And then you can just say,
look like give it to the feds. And then the feds come in. Like,
it's the only way that you would actually be able to address this issue,
in my opinion, around the country in a real way,
that would actually stand up over time.
Unfortunately, the feds right now, uh, is a Trump administration fed.
And so there's no appetite there to actually do this with this current
administration.
We've never had a department of justice interested in justice. Yeah.
They might want to rename them themselves.
You go with like a new one that actually gets after the people's work.
There are a lot of other things that we should do. I mean,
a lot of the things in the Democrats bill were spot on around banning choke
holds and getting data. Like one, one problem is that if you have a bad cop,
that cop can just go three counties over and all of a sudden get hired again.
Uh, and, um, you know, you,
it's a situation where you actually aren't even sure of the magnitude of the
problem.
That's one reason I went looking for the data because police departments don't
actually report how many people die in contact with police officers every year,
even though they're legally required to do so, which, you know,
it's a terrible problem.
If like no one even knows how bad the problem is like that that's a terrible,
terrible sign in just about any, any environment.
So there is also so much work to do on this side. Karen,
certainly I think cash relief is part of this too. When I said that,
would George Floyd have been there? Um, in that situation,
if everyone was getting one to $2,000 a month, you know,
I think that there was some issue around like, you know,
him needing to pay for something. And like people suspected the currency,
et cetera, et cetera.
Like let's just get real money in everyone's hands and then make it so that
fewer people of color are having run-ins with, uh, police, uh, for, for like,
you know, like everyday interactions or issues.
As you sit home now and watch,
as we trip into November, you're no longer running.
I, you endorsed Joe Biden, but I don't think it's a cakewalk.
I don't think it's going to be a runaway.
I think it's going to be a very difficult victory.
And I actually am nervous about whether or not he could pull us out.
Have you been having conversations with him about the person he selects his
vice-president,
which I think is going to be probably the most important vice-presidential pick
in our history. What's going to be your role in a Biden administration.
Cause there should be one and,
and give us something to hold onto Andrew Yang in terms of what you see
happening in November regarding this election.
I talked to Joe last week, uh, and I'm really very,
very positive on his chances of becoming our next president. And I, again,
I'm the numbers guy where, you know, the polls let us down in 2016,
but the polls are pretty freaking uniform this time around.
And they're even more extreme than they were last time.
I think Hillary had a point in like the, like, uh, maybe a four point lead,
like Joe's lead is something like twice that,
and the lead holds up in places like Florida and Michigan,
like according to the polls, Texas is up for grabs. You know,
you got to look up and say like,
if you're the average American who voted for Donald Trump,
are you eager to sign up for four more years of this? You know, you're like,
you're seeing your economy shot to pieces. You're seeing people dying.
You're seeing him just like in, in flame, uh,
racial problems instead of trying to heal them. Like the,
even the average Trump voter has to look around and being like,
this is not good.
Like 72% of Americans said that this is the worst time in American history that
they can ever ever remember. Uh, so that's 72%, you know what I mean?
I don't know what the other 28% of people are. Maybe they're really old.
And they remember something very, very, very awful. Uh,
but if 72% of Americans think you're in the worst time in American history and
their lifetimes, that's not like let's, re-elect like the current president,
like that's a very, very anti incumbent, uh, type atmosphere.
So I think Joe wins, uh, you know, but then after Joe wins,
the work begins. We have so much work to do.
We have to reinvent this economy so that it works for everyone listening to this
for families and towns that are being shattered right now. And I will,
uh, be part of the administration of Joe wants me to be, um,
one of the things that they have floated by me is to try and address our data
rights and, uh, technology issues, uh, things that the government frankly,
is way behind on. Uh,
and Joe has expressed some openness and enthusiasm for trying to build up
some kind of tech facing team. Uh, and I may be part of that team.
As a, as it relates to that.
When I think about how far as other parts of the world are in terms of
protecting privacy individual, the privacy of individuals,
particularly as it relates to our privacy from our tech providers
put into perspective what we,
what we sort of are giving the way without any modicum of regulation here
or without legislators really understands technology.
Yeah. We're giving away in dollar terms, hundreds of billions of dollars a year.
Like if you look at Facebook and Google Facebook's revenue is 70 billion a year,
Google is 160 billion a year. Uh, that's almost a hundred percent advertising.
And so they're making all that money based on selling and reselling our data
to advertisers.
And we all had the experience where you leave Facebook and the ads follow you
around. You know,
you have some kind of Facebook conversation about a beach vacation,
and all of a sudden like Aruba ads are being shown to you,
like when you're on a totally different site. So, so that's, uh, so,
so that's eerie and spooky. And number one is like,
we're not seeing a dime of that.
If our data's worth 200 billion a year plus like why are we not
seeing a red cent? So that's messed up. Uh,
the fact that our preferences and opinions are subject to so much of this,
um, interference,
some of it which may be corrupt or even foreign or, uh,
ideologically extreme, like that's a mess. Uh,
the fact that our mental health is actually diminishing particularly for young
people, particularly for young girls in part,
because of the way that social media incentives are set up where,
and I use social media a lot, you know, yang gang and all of that. But, uh, the,
the fact is that if you're the social media company,
you get paid based upon trying to advertise to us.
And so everything you do is going to be designed to try and maximize engagement
and snap streaks and the rest of it. And so if you're a 14 year old girl and,
uh, you know, you're, you're getting cyber bullied or whatnot,
or being subject to various negative influences,
like there's no counterweight within that tech company, uh,
to try and look out for our kids. It's all about who, what the advertisers want,
like how they can make the most money. So it's bad for our, our, uh,
sense of self, our humanity, our pocket books and wallets,
our democracy and our mental health what's going on right now with our data.
And I would love to turn that around.
I'm working on things right now to try and turn that around.
But I think the Biden administration is going to move light years as fast.
What do you do a fair bit of your life, ideally sleep?
How do you do it on a mattress?
What do you need a mattress that you can sleep on?
And happily helix sleep offers just that it's a
high-end mattress and they send to you antibiotics.
You just busted out and then snuggle up on a pillow.
I think they drove a free pill and I do this action. Uh, and they've won awards.
They were like the overall mattress pick of 2019 and 2020 by GQ and
wired magazine. So, you know,
there was some wired editor to sleeping on these mattresses being like,
this is the one, one, again,
they chose helix sleep and we to our fans just go to helix,
sleep.com/yang, take their two minutes sleep quiz,
which is fun because you get to answer questions about how you sleep and they'll
match you with a customized mattress that gives you the best sleep of your life.
What is the best sleep of your life? Feel like? I don't know,
but you can find out and they'll give you a 10 year warranty.
Can you try it out for a hundred nights?
You can sleep on that mattress for three months,
the risk-free and I'll even pick it up for you if you don't love it,
but you will. That's a lot of confidence in those mattress.
So go to sleep.com and they're offering $200 off all
mattress orders, two free pillows for our listeners@helixsleep.com slash yang.
That's helix ATL, sleep.com/ $200 off.
I just did this. I took the quiz you put in your name,
you can put in your partner's name, you can choose the side that you want.
That's firm or soft. If you sleep on your back, you sleep on your side.
Do you have back pain in the morning? Do you not? Then they,
this magical wheel spins, and then it tells you a mattress to order,
and then they ship it to you in a box and a bed frame. And if you use our code,
you get two free pillows and $200 off. So it is as easy as advertise.
It's beautiful. It's comfortable, it's simple helix sleep.com slashing $200 off.
As I'm listening to you again, I'm lamenting man. You know,
it would be nice. And if you live in New York, uh, as we, you know,
drew does from time to time, I'm wondering if you are going to throw your hat,
are you going to announce on this show today that you're going to be running for
mayor of New York? I'm just curious.
I love the question just in that, like, it's,
it's incredibly invigorating to be considered for it. Um,
right now I'm focused on helping Joe win, get Trump out, like get,
get a new team in. Did he see? And then we'll look at, uh,
the opportunities for air for, you know, for me the,
in terms of how to have a positive impact, but I love New York.
I certainly want to see New York back on its feet as soon as possible.
And, and on that, you're a father, you're raising kids in New York. Uh,
there's this drum beat from the president to St.
Kids back into the classroom and or else,
or else funding will be withheld. What are your thoughts on that?
As somebody that also has children in the New York city school system.
I have a con I have conversation with my wife about this on the regular,
as you know, we are all having within our households.
And there is real truth to the fact that like, there are,
you know, a million different situations around the country,
and there are real harms to not having your kids in school. Like, you know,
like we, we all saw the beginnings of it with our kids being out in the spring.
Uh, and if you have that, uh,
at home time compound in the fall,
like some of these kids will be significantly behind, uh,
and their development will be, you know, less than what you want it to be.
Now that's one side of the equation. What is the other side, like,
how safe do people feel like if you send your kids into school, like,
are, are you confident really that, you know, in my case,
like seven year olds are going to social distance from each other,
of course not their kids. Like, you know,
like the odds of them all like wearing masks and staying like six feet away from
each other are approximately zero. So,
so you have to look at that at the other side and say, okay, like, you know,
what are the health concerns now? Where are the teachers on this? And I,
you know, you, you know,
teachers are going to be obviously mixing with these kids on the, um, like, uh,
um, on the regular. Um,
and so th there are real massive issues to balance.
It's not like a black or white, or like, you know,
right or wrong thing in my mind,
because there are so many different situations for different kids,
different families, different communities.
If you're in a part of the country where frankly COVID is not rampant and like,
you know, your kids need school then like,
ideally your school does reopen in your kids back in that school.
If you're in a community where COVID is spreading,
like wildfire and hospitals don't have capacity, then it's a very,
very different picture. I'm happy to say,
it seems like New York now is edging towards like, uh,
being one of the clearer environments,
because we've taken it seriously because we had to pay such a tragic,
devastating price early on.
Yeah. But it also, uh, there's no cure yet. And so,
uh, you can be clear today and not tomorrow 14 days later,
uh, there could be another wave. So I just UN on that, you know,
th this president, um, took, uh,
took the opportunity to constantly refer to this virus as the China virus or the
flu and things like that. And as a man from the, with an Asian background,
what were your thoughts and what was he trying to do?
And what was the impact that the fallout from that?
No, I was talking to a family member about this. Like,
Trump's like a basketball player who has like one move. And then like,
if you take the move away, he doesn't know what else to do.
He just keeps going to it. So in his case, it's like,
my move is racially inflammatory and divisive rhetoric.
And if I'm getting called the task for the fact that I've let this pandemic, uh,
run rampant and wreck the economy and kill tens of thousands Americans,
maybe if I call it the China virus or cold flu, or like UConn flu or whatever,
like I can like change the conversation and just like make it so that people are
angry at each other or distracted. Uh, so from my perspective, it was like,
look, let's just focus on the real issues that we all care about,
which is our health, our family's health,
whether our kids are gonna go back to school and like, keep the focus on, uh,
the fact that this administration has failed us in historic mammoth fashion.
Um, so clearly as an Asian American, obviously I think that that,
that kind of stuff is nonsense and hateful and divisive.
Um, but I just don't want it to work. Like, you know, just to like,
keep the focus on the president's performance and then we'll get him out of
there. And then we can start to heal the country and do the hard work of digging
ourselves out.
It would be nice to ignore it, but there were people that were actually,
you know, uh, abused attacks as a result of this. So.
Friends too,
I mean like the hatred and fear and hostility
towards Asian Americans has surged to a level that, you know,
friends and family have never seen before. And like, you know,
kids being stabbed and like people being beaten,
like an acid being thrown in someone's face randomly, like, you know, just real,
real, uh.
Venom and hatred that has no place in America. Um,
yeah, it, it, it, it's heartbreaking, you know, and like different, but the,
the thing I try and put back in perspective, it's like, well, I mean,
you also have, African-Americans dying of COVID at like three,
four or five times the rate of other Americans. I mean,
like we're all suffering in different ways. Um, and you know,
like to me,
like the goal has to be trying to do as much good as possible and get a sound
and,
and not let certainly president Trump distract us from what's most important.
It's the age old question.
How do you find the people you're looking for when you're looking to hire for
business? And on the flip side,
how do you find someone who's looking for someone just like you indeed is a
great way for both employers and folks who are looking to take the next step,
uh, in terms of finding a job that's gonna pay the bills,
keep everyone's head above water.
So when Andrew and I were running a campaign,
we ended up having to hire hundreds of people.
In the matter of two to three weeks. It was the most insane time of campaign.
I can't tell you how stressed the staff was.
And tech platforms like indeed were our saving grace,
where you're able to just find quick talent,
understand where they're coming from, where they are, their experience,
their specific expertise,
or identify their professional focuses and build to them very quickly.
Interview hire as fast as possible. So we are big fans of indeed.
And without platforms like this, I can't tell you how. And we were already,
we were already breaking things and moving as fast as we could.
I can't say how much messier would have been on the campaign.
So if you're a small business or medium-sized business looking to hire and hire
fast, indeed is the place to go for sure.
And you can get started with a three $75 credit for your first job codes to give
it a try and get in front of quality candidates,
go to indeed.com/yang. That's a
d.com/yang through September 30th,
75 bucks off your first job post to see whether it works for you and your
business.
So now what is, you know, I wait until November,
I just feel on some level, not helpless because, you know,
as long as we have breath in our body,
we can make a difference whether we're talking about our community in our,
in our own backyard, but it does feel like we're, we're,
it's a waiting game to November to see what happens,
because as long as that man is in office pardoning for
guilty abusing the power, um, that,
that he has been imbued with. And it's disgusting, you know,
as a student of history to watch this abuse,
that office in this manner, you know, uh, I just feel like we're,
we're in a holding pattern until November.
Karen. There's so much for us to do between now and then, uh,
certainly number one, um, uh, is some of these local races,
like I was excited for Jamaal Bowman. I'm excited for, uh,
some of the folks that my organization's endorsing right now.
We've got a primary tomorrow on Tuesday in Austin, Texas, uh,
this great candidate, Donna, I M a is running that I endorsed. So like,
literally like every week,
there's like another race that I'm like trying to pump, uh,
energy and resources and votes towards, uh, yeah, like the, uh,
there's another candidate who just came out as a mayor for universal basic
income, Alex Morris in, um, uh, Massachusetts.
Who's great freaking brilliant guys for your basic income. Um,
so if we can get some folks into DC, one of the things,
so we started this conversation on emergency cash relief, which I'm clearly, uh,
a hundred percent behind. And to me, how can you be a member of Congress?
Who's a Democrat and not be for cash relief, you know, like, like you're,
you need to go. And we need to get someone in there who will actually say like,
look during our pandemic, giving money to people is obvious. So right now,
41, uh, representatives and like a smaller number of members of Congress,
including Kamala Harris and Bernie and ed Markey support the cash relief bill.
And one of the ways we can get cash relief passed is by having members of
Congress who are not for cash relief, have challengers come up and say,
I'm for cash relief. Why the heck are you not for cash relief?
And then you either get the current member out and a new person in who's
forecast relief, or you put pressure on the current person to switch.
Um, and so that to me is like,
job one right now is we got to call our members of Congress and say, look,
you're going to pass another stimulus bill, which they will.
I guarantee you another stimulus bill bills coming.
You got to get more of it for the people, for us, for the humans.
We do not care about the mega Corp's.
They can go into bankruptcy for all we care. Like I care about myself, my aunt,
my friends, my neighbors get us the money. And so we need to make that case.
And one great way to make that case is by like supporting people who are for it.
And if you're not for it, you need to go. So, so that's immediate. Um,
another thing that we can do is, is, uh,
just lend a hand, like thanks to some people like Jack Dorsey,
like my organization's given, uh, almost $7 million in direct economic relief,
including a million dollar straight to a thousand families in the Bronx, uh,
earlier, um, in the spring. I can't believe it's summer now. That's crazy.
Uh, so, so, uh,
so we need to just lend a hand because there's so much suffering so many people
and we can't wait until, uh, DC gets its act together.
Like we just gotta do everything we can to put people on a better path when
we've been giving this $250 or 500, a thousand dollars to people,
Karen tears of joy, you know,
it's like it's incredibly invigorating and saddening at the same time that
there are so many Americans that if you gave them 500 bucks,
it would be like the difference between eating and not eating or being able to
feed their kids and not feed their kids.
So anything we can do to help on that side, we should do. Uh,
and for what it's worth, Andrew Yang is very positive.
How to participate in that. Oh, I would love that. Uh,
so our organization's website is move humanity forward.com. Uh,
we've given 7 million in direct economic relief, any money you give to us,
we're going to turn around and give to someone in need. Uh, and yeah,
hopefully we can get, get up to that $10 million level pretty quick. Um,
but the need is so vast. You can also request help out that website. Uh, so if,
when you're listening to this and you need a hand, you can put your name down.
It's pretty quick. Um, we do have a massive waiting list now. Um,
so no promises, but if you need help, please do just put your name down.
And if you can provide help, uh,
give what you can and we'll turn it around and give it to someone else.
It's the age old question.
How do you find the people you're looking for when you're looking to hire for
business? And on the flip side,
how do you find someone who's looking for someone just like you indeed is a
great way for both employers and folks who are looking to take the next step,
uh, in terms of finding a job, that's going to pay the bills,
keep everyone's head above water.
So when Andrew and I were running the campaign,
we ended up having to hire hundreds of people.
In the matter of two to three weeks. It was the most insane time of campaign. I,
I can't tell you how stressed the staff was.
And tech platforms like indeed were our saving grace,
where you're able to just find quick talent,
understand where they're coming from, where they are, their experience,
their specific expertise,
or identify their professional focuses and filter them very quickly.
Interview hire as fast as possible. So we are big fans of indeed.
And without platforms like this, I can't tell you how. And we were already,
we were already breaking things and moving as fast as we could.
I can't say how much messier would have been on the campaign.
So if you're a small business or medium sized business,
looking to hire and hire fast, indeed is the place to go for sure.
And you can get started with a three $75 credit for your first job coach to give
it a try and get in front of quality candidates,
go to indeed.com/yang. That's a
d.com/yang through September 30th,
seventy-five bucks off your first job post to see whether it works for you and
your business.
[Inaudible] curious what you think about.
Some of the large corporations that are now starting to,
to pledge dollars to communities, particularly,
I'm thinking about the dollars place to the African-American community,
your racial or social justice, or even some of the organization,
some of the corporations they're pledging dollars for COVID, uh,
their COVID response. What,
what would you advise those organizations, those companies,
where to spend that money, how to actually make that money me,
or what should we be should be looking for asking for,
from those organizations that they're saying, we're going to give these dollars,
we're going to make these, these donations in these checks.
What should we be looking for or asking them to do with that money?
I'm a huge fan of direct relief. Uh, you know,
like if the money was going straight into people's wallets and pocketbooks,
that would be ideal. I like it.
When firms stand up and try and do the right thing, they say like, Hey, look,
I'm going to give $5 million to, uh,
communities of color I've been in those offices.
And you know what they do when they're in this situation,
they look around and say, okay, who can we give the money to?
That will stand up to like a very,
very high degree of corporate scrutiny or press scrutiny.
And then they'll try and identify various nonprofits that
are reputable and can be trusted.
And then maybe if you have 5 million to give to communities of color, you say,
look, find me the five top nonprofits that are working on various issues.
And then you give them each a million. Each you have press releases.
Those leaders are happy. Great, love it.
How much of that money ends up reaching folks who are desperate right now for
groceries and the rest of it? Probably not quite as much as you'd hope,
you know, and, and, and not to be mad at anything that's going on. Like,
I've run a nonprofit that I started. You know, if you gave us a million bucks,
like, uh, we'd be incredibly grateful. We do great stuff with it.
We'd pay our people first, obviously, because you know,
like it's not like these nonprofits are swimming in resources necessarily all
the time. So like some good work could be done,
but there'd be a lot of people that would never see a dime of that. Um,
and so it, it's a different type of challenge, but if you're a company,
you feel like you gotta go to a name brand partner.
Uh, w do you run, I've been having this conversation just about every week, uh,
because we know what you just said is true,
and we need to do more of what you're actually doing. Move, move,
humanity forward, move humanity forward.com. So, Andrew,
first of all, thank you for being here today. Uh, we appreciate you.
We appreciate the partnership. You're a guy that really does care about people,
and that's important to us here, uh, just in general,
because everyone is so political. Everything's so political. Everything's about,
you know, putting on the right face and,
and saying the right things and having the right soundbites,
you actually do care. And that was what you ran for president on,
and you're still it. So, uh, um,
I'm really grateful that you're part of this family here. I'll tell you.
Karen, I'm grateful to you for having me on back when I was running. Now,
I'll come back anytime and we just have to do what's right for us and our
people. We know, like if you talk to the average person, like, you know,
they know how to solve their own problems best.
We just got to get money into your hands.
So you can actually solve your own problems.
When we were looking to give a million bucks away to the folks in the Bronx,
like I was like, we have to make it. So every dime goes to a human,
like I do not want to be like, again, not mad at nonprofits, like run one,
but we got to like find a thousand people and give them a thousand bucks. Um,
and we did it. I was very, very proud of that. We need more like that,
where we just gotta get money into people's hands. And remember the Congress,
this is the only silver lining can we're in a deep dark hole.
It's a terrible catastrophic time,
but there's a huge appetite to do something differently. Again,
74% of Americans want cash relief.
Like we're going to get president Biden and then we're going to need a new,
new deal.
And it's going to be hopefully a chance to write some of the wrongs that have
been weighing our countries.
For generations. Alexis have consequences, people,
you got to vote and you gotta take care of business. And Andrew Yang,
you come back anytime, sir. I appreciate you follow him, gang gang.
Thank you for listening in. I hope you enjoyed this conversation. If you did,
please do subscribe to yang,
speaks and click on notifications so we can let you know every time we have a
new episode.